So now what we want to do is calculate calculate what
the CDF?
Now that we've managed to standardize our normal distribution we can
use CDF.
and if you want to denote CDF
like I said
P uppercase
so what are we taking or what
is the argument that you're passing to
CDF to our CDF? What are we trying to measure we are
trying to measure.
both machines
But let's do the first one.
What? Okay. What is the
So we want to know what is the probability?
that
Z sub 1
What is the probability that Z sub 1?
or false somewhere between
a that's 2.9 centimeters and
B that's 3.1 centimeters the
experiments when this machine starts producing
corks one after the other after the other after the
other
What is the probability?
that
it will have quirks that will fall within 2.9 centimeters
and 3.1 centimeters.
And then we will do the same thing again.
for the second machine
So let's put them to the test.
Now we know what kind of question Depot was
mathematically that Z sub one. Let's focus on
the first machine. These sub one is between 2.9 3.1
now because we standardized
x sub 1 to Z sub 1 using the standard transformation.
Formula, we also have to standardize.
A and B
we have to standardize these these tools have
to be adjusted for
the transformation
Okay.
Which means we will have to re-express this.
The same way as the in a similar way we expressed.
What do you call it?
Z sub 1
so this will be changed to it's actually
bring this in here.
That's actually bring this into here.
So we have to standardize.
A and B so we go p
over Sigma
okay, subtract both numbers by the population mean
of course the population mean for the first machine.
The first machine has a standard deviation
3 and excuse me mean three standard deviation.
What is it 0.1?
Okay, so mu is not.
It's not fixed.
Mu and sigma will be different for Z1 and there
will be different for Z2.
Okay, so let's begin. Let's be careful with that.
Okay. So now we've standardized around
the variable. We've standardized the
the range in which we want.
the corks to
Fall in now. We can actually go ahead and bring in
the five function.
to calculate
the probability
now I'm not going to type everything in here because I think you have the idea.
Let me just do the same thing for
the second machine
second machine. I'm in second.
random variable
for these up to
okay will be the same one except this was these up to
okay, and now let's go ahead
and
I would reveal the answer because the answer has
everything typed in nicely.
And we'll take it from there.